i didn't give uh my kids been a drill
one night
and i was having sex with uh she's here
uh
i'm talking about you uh
having sex with my wife
and um things are going very well
and i felt this finger
touch my ass
now listen
when you're married and a finger touches
your ass you're like okay is is that
what we're doing tonight like
because married sex is regular you have
regular sex and every now and then
somebody has too many drinks he's like
let's try this and you're like
you're always like i didn't know we were
doing i had a [ __ ] shower if i knew
we were doing that tonight you know what
i mean like
is this what's going down tonight yeah
and plus there's no way she's touching
my ass she was handcuffed but um
so
i turn around and we see it's our
youngest son jacob and he's at the end
of the bed he's probably three and a
half at the time
and oh
and um he's he's sitting there and he's
doing this you know that age when they
did that
and beth just pulls the covers over her
head and she goes
handle it
so
i she's under the covers that means i'm
out of the covers and i'm just at the
end of the bed just
dick out just
hey buddy
you know and he was just sitting there
and he was going he was like
and by the way
jacob has always stood like forrest gump
i have no idea what
this dude's always been like hey
lieutenant like i have no idea this is
always
so he's standing there and he goes
what are you doing
and i said
telling mom jokes
and everybody has their thing that you
tell your kids when they walk in on you
you know what i mean some people like
i'm giving your mom a back rub i'm
cleaning your mom's face whatever it is
[Applause]
[Laughter]
sorry about that he's never said that to
your mom just other people's moms you
know and so uh
no he didn't say that to other people's
moms either you know what i'm gonna stop
talking to you guys um
so
i go and by the way i'd always say i'm
telling your mom jokes because he would
ask me what do you do for a living and
i'd be like well i tell jokes and he'd
go oh
do people laugh i'm like yeah people
laugh
is it is it is it good when people laugh
yeah it's good when people laugh oh
so he goes uh
what are you doing
i said i'm telling mom jokes and he goes
she's not laughing
well she was before you came in
and he goes this was my favorite part he
just looks at me up and down naked still
dick out and just goes
you're silly and just walks out of the
room
so and by the way
and people watching and i know there are
a lot of kids watching with their
parents and you're here thank god so i
can say this and make you guys
uncomfortable
here's something you need to know and
look deep into my eyes kids i know
you're sitting next to your parents
here's something you need to know
your parents [ __ ] here's the deal here's
what you need to know your parents your
parents they [ __ ] and your mom i'm not
saying about your mom your mom's a good
mom
but she's a bad girl you know what i'm
saying
your mom cuts the crust off your
sandwich but she's also been like this
with your dad's junk stop it stop doing
that it's not funny anymore stop that
you know what i mean so
a lot of things you don't know about
your parents
we tell you something else you don't
know about your parents you know what
they they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're doing when the the
thing you realize the most when you
become a parent is you like oh my
parents had no idea what the [ __ ] was
happening they just made
and they're watching so
but um they just made things up as they
went you know and we we'd do the same
thing with you guys
um
so i thought by the way
i thought okay
he saw me he said walked in but we're
gonna be fine he hasn't mentioned
anything you know
and then we were out at the park
and uh and by the way when he left the
room i said to beth i'm like
we're still
having sex right
she goes no
jacob was just in here i'm like yeah but
he's
he's not here now
she was like no and i go are you sure
she goes
i'll just lay here and i was like okay
i think i think it's funny that women
think that's a deal breaker when they're
like fine i'll just lay here every guy's
like that's cool i'm on board for that
you're just gonna
you're saying yes but you're gonna be
still cool no problem with that at all
yeah
[Laughter]
that is not a deal breaker at all i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna lay here and
it's so funny i tried to i tried to tell
her that like it just shows you how
attracted i am to you and she's like all
i hear is that you would [ __ ] a tree and
i'm like well that too but
i don't want to say no to the tree out
of hand that seems mad you know
so
jakey and i at the park
and um
he comes up to me and he goes
i know what you tell for jokes
and i go you do
and by the way
he used to ask me what do you tell for
jokes and i go what do you think i tell
for jokes and you go i think you just do
things like this
and i'm like you're not that far off uh
yeah i mean you're in the ballpark at
least you know and so he um he goes i
know you tell for jokes
and i go
what
and he goes well i know a joke you
should tell
i go tell me and he goes
i think you should tell that joke about
your penis sticking straight up
and we're at the park in public guys i'm
like hey man uh
inside voice bro you know what i'm
saying like uh i said what he goes that
joke about your penis sticking straight
up you should tell people are going to
laugh
i'm going no no he's going to laugh at
that man he goes i did i laughed a lot
and i was like first of all [ __ ] you uh
that's not nice but he became obsessed
obsessed
with
my junk like he just could not stop
any time he got a chance like i was
coming out of the shower once and it was
at that age where you know the kid might
be a little too scared to go in the
shower by himself so you kind of cross
paths and you wait in the bathroom with
him on he takes a shower and we were
crossing paths
and he just started staring at my junk
just
and i went for the towel and he goes no
no no no no
wait a second
i grabbed the towel and i was like first
of all dude
don't squint what are you squinting at
that is not a nice thing to do
and he said your
your penis is bigger than mine
and you want folks no matter how the
other person is
it's always nice to hear that you know
what i mean like i i didn't know i
needed to hear it i was like you're a
good son i i really like that you know
[Music]
[Music]
you